the supreme court has now said that it
will decide whether to prohibit the use
of race conscious admissions in higher
education
according to the wall street journal
it's agreeing to consider challenges to
policies at both harvard and the
university of north carolina the court
in a brief written order on monday said
it would consider a pair of challenges
by a group called students for fair
admissions it's been led by the
conservative legal activist edward blum
they sued both schools on the same day
in 2014.
the lawsuit against harvard alleged that
the school uses quota-like racial
balancing tactics that artificially
raised the standards of admission for
asian american applicants in violation
of federal civil rights law the
challengers alleged asians were admitted
at a lower rate than whites even though
their overall academic scores were
better harvard rejected the claims of
discrimination said it only considered
race in a flexible way as one factor
among many in building diverse classes
of students well why is it even being
considered as a factor at all
couldn't you just look at for example
life challenges without looking at race
why is race considered a life challenge
in the united states explicitly and why
is it even a matter of inquiry for
schools to determine that your race is a
relevant factor in whether you ought to
be admitted to a school
i mean it is a pretty overt racism when
students get in with 200 points less on
the sats then this asian student over
here just because this asian student
happens to be asian
this is what they used to do to jews at
colleges in the united states now
they're doing it to asians in the united
states it's absurd on its face it is
wild racism from the left and yet the
left continues to double down on this
because obviously asians are a supposed
model minority according to the left
whereas black americans are indubitably
put upon and therefore black americans
only need a 1300 or a 1200 to get into
harvard whereas asians needed 19 000 to
get on
they need to get a 19 000 on their sats
in order to get into harvard
under the trump administration the
justice department actually supported
that lawsuit the biden era department
abandoned that position and offered
support for harvard in a legal brief
last month urging the supreme court to
turn away the challenge
the lawsuit against the university of
north carolina was similar to the
harvard allegations but added claims
that the flagship public university in
chapel hill violated the constitution's
guarantee of equal protection
so with a private school the challenge
is going to be that it violates the
civil rights act with the public school
the the challenge is going to be that
violates the 14th amendment the
challengers allege that the school
unlawfully factored students race into
the admissions process favoring black
hispanic and native american applicants
and even caused them harm by inviting
them into classrooms for which they
weren't prepared
which is true
the the thurnstroms
who used to write for the atlantic they
documented very well the the phenomenon
of misalignment in which students are
admitted to schools that they actually
are not prepared for and then they tend
to flunk out of those schools at a
higher rate
unc and court papers says it has made
progress on diversity but continues to
face challenges in admitting
underrepresented minorities now the
truth is that supreme court precedent
here has been ridiculous because supreme
court said that for some reason
diversity is in and of itself a public
good i'm not sure why they never really
explained why diversity is a public good
if they said that a wide range of human
experiences is worthwhile to pursue in
student body settings that might be
better but when they say racial
diversity itself is some sort of public
good there's no reason why that should
be
also the diversity standards tend to be
wildly inaccurate so for example if you
have a classroom full of black students
this is considered diverse if you have
an entire classroom filled with asian
students it's considered not diverse
enough
nobody can explain why
both are monochrome but only one type of
monochrome is diverse according to the
left here is jen saki however trying to
defend the biden administration pushing
over racism on nation against asian
americans
we strongly believe this administration
in the benefits of diversity in higher
education and we take very seriously our
commitment to advancing equity and equal
opportunity for historically underserved
populations
okay but they're going to have to
explain why this is capable of violating
constitutional precept now the fact the
supreme court is even considering it
again is really interesting because in
2016 the court ruled that the university
of texas in austin's process passed
constitutional muster despite the fact
that it took race into account
that was an absurd ruling it was a 4-3
court and justice anthony kennedy was
the deciding justice in that particular
case he joined the left of course
ginsburg breyer and sotomayor saying
universities are defined by intangible
qualities which make for greatness he
said considerable deference is owed to a
university in defining those intangible
characteristics well they seem pretty
tangible when you're barring asians just
to be fair it seems like kind of
tangible to the asian student who scored
a 1580 on his sat then got barred
because he happened to be asian
but this is something that the left
loves to push this is one of their
favorite things by the way they don't
just want it to apply at colleges
because nothing that starts in college
ends in college for the left
the washington post editorial board has
an entire piece today about how every
company in america should be forced to
quote unquote diversify its boardroom
quote the securities and exchange
commission last summer approved a
proposal by nasdaq to require that most
boards of directors among the exchanges
approximately 3 000 companies include at
least one woman as well as at least one
person of color and or one lgbtq person
nasdaq's initiatives was groundbreaking
for us securities exchange it's not very
novel in other contexts california
already had laws mandating the public
companies headquartered in state have
women and by 2023 members of
underrepresented communities on their
boards
many european countries require more
gender diversity than the nasdaq even in
visions
but this is good according to the
washington post it's very encouraging
because more progress is needed luckily
there are plenty of incentives for firms
to make such strides and not just
political and public pressure okay so
here is the deal these companies
all they do is they find some sort of
placeholder and they just add seeds to
the board and then they put that
placeholder on the board to ensure that
they are not sued by the government but
the reality of course is that businesses
are going to continue to run it's an
absurdity on its face and it's very very
silly
but again it is unearned moral
superiority of the left that is the
deciding factor here even when that
means active discrimination against more
qualified applicants in college or
against members of the board who ought
to be there as opposed to being
leveraged onto the board by the
government
the government has no business in this
area and by the way neither does nasdaq
or the s or or the or the new york stock
exchange
it's ridiculous
the solution the companies are gonna
find is to have a useless board member
that they add and pay a little bit of a
salary or never go public in the first
place that will be the actual answer to
this problem
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe